>> RALLYING TONIGHT IN SUPPORT
OF MARSHA BLACKBURN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT AFTER THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP.
WATCH THIS.
>> HE’S AN ABSOLUTE TOOL OF
CHUCK SCHUMER.
HE’S A TOOL OF CHUCK SCHUMER,
AND OF COURSE, THE MS13 LOVER
NANCY PELOSI.
I SAID THEY ARE ANIMALS, AND SHE
SAID HOW DARE YOU SAY THAT?
HOW DARE YOU SAY THAT?
HAVE YOU SEEN WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE?
HAVE YOU SEEN WHAT THEY ARE
DOING TO US?
AND WE ARE TAKING THEM OUT OF
THE COUNTRY BY THE THOUSANDS.
>> JOINING US NOW ASSISTANT TO
THE PRESIDENT, FOX NEWS
STRATEGIST AND CONTRIBUTOR
FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT.
THE ELECTION, I THINK IS THE
BIGGEST MOST IMPORTANT MIDTERM.
IT WILL BE ABOUT TAKING BACK THE
TAX CUTS, ABOUT IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT AND UNDOING AN
ELECTION AND A LOT OF THINGS THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT TONIGHT.
>> TONIGHT WAS A BARN STORMER.
I STARTED TICKING OFF THE THINGS
HE COVERED, AND I RAN OUT OF
SPACE.
UP FOR THE FLAG, SECOND
AMENDMENT, REBUILDING THE
MILITARY, TAX CUTS, SENATE OR
HOUSE, THIS IS THE SPEECH THAT
NAILED THE REPUBLICAN WAVE, NOT
THE DEMOCRAT WAVE.
I’M NOT GOING TO SAY BLUE WAVE.
IT’S OUR COLOR.
IF THERE IS ANY PARTY THAT’S
RED, IT’S THE DEMOCRATS.
TONIGHT, IT’S SPECTACULAR.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THEY HAVE TO
RUN ON.
BRINGING BACK ISIS?
CUTTING YOUR TAXES?
LETTING MORE MS13 INTO THE
COUNTRY.
IT WAS FABULOUS.
>> I THINK THIS IS THE BIGGEST
ELECTION OF OUR LIFETIME.
WE WANT TO DO IT, BUT DON’T TELL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT’S A LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, SEAN.
IF WE LOSE THE HOUSE, THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE IMPEACHED FOR
NOTHING, BECAUSE HE WON AN
ELECTION.
I THOUGHT THE LINE OF THE NIGHT
WAS THE MS13 LINE.
THIS IS THE GIFT OF DONALD
TRUMP, RIGHT?
DONALD TRUMP GETS THE DEMOCRATS
TO SHOW THEIR BUTTS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ALL THE TIME.
THEY GETS THEM TO DEFEND MS13,
HAMAS AND THE NORTH KOREANS IN
THE SPAN OF THE LAST MONTH.
THAT’S YOUR DEMOCRATS OF THE
NICE JOB, PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE’S THE ONLY ONE THAT COULD
HAVE DONE THAT.
THE MEDIA, IT’S LIKE A BREAKUP
LETTER.
WITHIN 24 HOURS, KIM JUNG UN’S
PEOPLE, LITTLE ROCKET MAN
BEGGING TO MEET WITH THE